[Music]
hi my name is Allen Shan ski I'm an
intern on the Android team at Google and
today I'll be talking about lists you
dragging animations so the demo today is
going to be a simple list view where you
can tie a long click on an item then
drag it around and you'll see that as
you drag the item around it'll actually
replace and move around swab the
underlying data set with the other
ListView items so the main trick to
doing this animation was to realize that
we're not actually moving the views of
the ListView around but what you're
gonna do is create a bitmap drawable
overlay the bitmap drawable on top of
the list view and then as you're
dragging your finger around what's I
shouldn't happen is that we'll movie
moving the become drawable but not the
view which is actually contained inside
the listing so let's jump straight to a
demo and so here we have a here we have
just a list of cheeses we can click and
hold them on the items as is in order to
get hold of it and then as we drag it
around you'll see that the items around
it animate into place while swapping the
underlying data set change and moving
around furthermore if the bitmap
drawable if the hover view that we have
goes outside the bounds of the ListView
you can see that the list you start
scrolling and also at the same time
swapping elements as we need as we need
to same thing goes as same thing goes
when it's above the balance the ListView
when you let go of it the new item just
enemies back into place into the list
view and normal
normal ListView interactions ensue so
let's just jump straight the code the
main file to look at here is dynamic
ListView which is which extends a list
to your object and as you scroll down
the first important thing to see is that
we add an on an on long click item
listener so what happens when an item
has been selected via long click invent
we have to do a few things one we have
to determine what the position is of the
click down event we have to determine
what the item with which item was
selected and then we also retrieve the
view that was selected from that spot as
well as the item ID associate with it
then the important thing that's
happening is we call this method called
get and Eadie
you which returns a bitmap drawable and
what that does is capture the contents
of the view that was selected it takes a
screenshot of it adds the little black
border around that we saw right here in
get bitmap with border and the
screenshot is captured right here and
get get bitmap from view so once we
captured that once we captured a bitmap
and we insert it into the bitmap
drawable with the important thing to
note is that bitmap drawables have the
notion of bounds so by modifying the
bounds we can modify words
we're located and then when we draw it
on top of the ListView it'll move around
accordingly to where to how the bounds
are updated okay so moving on to the on
long item click listen or the important
thing to note is that when an item has
been selected via long item click event
there are there's a few things that we
need to do one you need to determine
what the position is of the down event
was you need to determine the item
number that was selected and you also
need to treat you need to retrieve the
view that was clicked as well so then
what we're going to do is call this
method called get an ad hover view which
is going all it's going to do is return
a bitmap drawable that has the same
contents as the view that was selected
using using a couple methods here below
we're going to capture this contents of
the screen add a black border around it
which you saw in the demo and then we'll
throw all of that into the bitmap
drawable which then will be overlaid
over a ListView
the important thing to note as a bitmap
drawables do have the notion of bounds
so if we do I'll beat the bounds of the
bitmap drawable we'll be able to move it
around accordingly on the screen to
where we want it to be in response to
the user touches that can get an ad
hover view the important thing to note
is that we have to make sure the
visibility of the view that was selected
is set to invisible so it's still going
to be in the list view and the bitmap
job is going to be overlaying the
ListView
but these two objects are completely
independent even though they correspond
in response to the user touches the
other trick that that was implemented in
order to do this item swapping animation
is to note that whenever you're going to
swap and swap an item you're only ever
going to swap it with the item right
above it or right below it so that's how
whenever a swap animation takes place or
a dragging event begins you always need
to retrieve the above item ID and the
led by returning true from state stable
item IDs in the stable array adapter
which is a customer that we implemented
in this project where you can what
you're essentially saying is that every
single item in your ListView has a
unique ID that you maintain yourself and
that will never change for that
corresponding object so these we know
that this above and below item ID will
never change for the above and below
views around which you're currently
animating there's some logic here and
get view for ID and get position right
for ID where I was able to actually
retrieve a view given some item ID and
do foot and vice-versa you can look at
this later in more detail if you're
interested in how I did and if you're
interested in seeing how I did that but
the important thing here is that in this
batch draw if I do have that bitmap
drawable it will be drawn onto the
screen so what I'm doing here if I'm not
in a dragging event then my hover cell
is going to be null I won't be drawing
anything if my hover cell is a non null
object then I will draw it it'll overlay
the ListView since I'm first calling
this Vedra and only then drawing the
hover so on top of it so now in on touch
event there's a few things I need to be
done when an action down occurs I don't
yet know whether or not dad's can become
a drawing event or not so I either way I
need to retrieve the x and y-coordinates
of the touch event then in action move
this is where I actually move the hover
cell in response to the user touches
firstly I I calculate the Delta in by
how much the user has already moved his
or her finger and then if I am indeed in
a dragging event then I need to offset
the balance of my hover cell so here I
also the balance I updated balance event
I call invalidate which will call
dispatch draw draw the ListView and then
draw the hover so on top of it the other
thing I need to do is call handle cell
switch which is where the logic for
determining whether an item cells swap
is going to take place the way this
works is I have a couple boolean's that
determine whether or not my moving sell
my bitmap drawable has been shifted up
or downwards enough to actually
completely overlap the cell that's above
or below it if that is the case
then I determine whether or not it was
indeed moved up or moved down and
retrieve the item ID corresponding to
the cell which will be swapped after I
do that I need to swab the elements in
the underlying data set change and
notify the adapter that data has in the
beach and deed been changed so what's
going to happen when the notify data set
change method is called is that the
ListView knows that the data is
different so it's going to invoke a
layout and everything in the list will
be redrawn before I do that I want to
make sure that the cells that I need to
be visible or invisible while the cell
that is still in the swapping in the
dragon event is still invisible so I
update those here and then I also update
my above and below view because now that
I saw swap hasn't yet occurred in the
data set
the one either either the cell above it
or below it is now different okay and
now the most important thing here to
actually have the cell animate into
place when a data so I've changed when a
data set change has occurred is on
pre-draw listener so what on pregel
listener does is give you a call back
where after on layout on measure and
only that i've been called so after all
the values for all of your of your views
all of your widget on screen have
already been updated but on draw has not
yet been called what this gives what
this lets you do is essentially it gives
you the power to access all the final
values that all the widgets will have
but before they've actually been drawn
onto the screen so you can do some
custom drawing here given the final
values and then once once this complete
you can let the you can return true for
all the cost and drop all the other
default drawing to actually take place
so now in on pre draw the important that
you always want to remove preacher
listener if you only want to get in here
once you and then what you want to do is
grab the cell that's being swapped not
the cell you're dragging but the cell
that's going to swap into the new place
you off set up by Delta Y because you
know that it's currently in its final
position but you want it to be in its
old position prior to the data set
change so we calculate this Delta Y we
said that to be the translation
and then we simply use an object
animator to animate the translation
while back to zero with some duration so
as you saw in the demo this will
actually achieve that sliding effect
when a dataset change has occurred
scrolling down furthermore we have swap
elements which is a simple method
swapping the underlying data set and
then touches event ended the only
important thing to note here is this
object animator that we create and all
this does is animate the bitmap drawable
back into its correct position in the
ListView when a user has lifted his
finger up from the from the phone as
well as reset all our default values
back to reset all our variables back to
their default values
the other important thing that um that
was really tricked to do is determining
how we can actually have the list you
scroll while you're dragging a cell and
making sure that all the up and above
and below item IDs get updated as we
need them to so here in handle mobile
scroll is a method that gets called when
we so handle mobile cell Scrolls and I
think it's that gets called every single
time the user moves his finger and that
calls this method here all this does is
use a few methods available in view to
determine whether or not the bounds of
the hover cell are either below or above
the bounds of the ListView if that is
the case then we'll call smooth scroll
by either up or downwards and return
true and by returning through what we're
saying is that we are in a scrolling
state in a manual scrolling set created
by the fact that the bounds are outside
the bounds of the ListView and if that
is true then we'll know that after a
scroll has completed we should continue
scrolling because we're still in this
manual scrolling state invoked by by the
bounds of the hover cell so in order to
do that we add the scroll listener right
here and what that does is every single
time an own scroll event has change has
has taken place it checks whether the
first or a last visible cell in the
ListView has been updated if that's the
case then that means that that new first
or last item is a potential candidate
for an above or below cell to be swapped
that means that we're going to change
those above and below item IDs so we
call those methods here and if and after
the scroll is completed we call handle
mogul scroll once again to keep that
scrolling event continuing and keep
calling smooth scroll by as long as the
balance are outside the bounds of the
listing
yep so pretty much you can look at the
code if you want for if you want to see
any more detail but this is a very you
can take dynamic list you extend it
including your project and that's how
you can achieve a ListView which can
then be dynamically rearranged using
user touch events thanks